[Musique]
oui alors le lien entre un navigateur et
un chirurgien vous connaissez tous la
blague du la différence entre dieu et un
chirurgien et c'est que dieu il se prend
pas pour un chirurgien
ça on le savait mais à quoi
reconnaîtriez vous un pilote de chasse
dans une soirée on la connaît moins
celle-là je vous défie voilà si ça vous
arrive vous le savez pas ce que façon
c'est lui qui va venir vous le dire on
soit reçue pilote de chasse on commence
à mieux saisir le lien entre ces deux
entités
ces deux personnes alors ça c'est mon
avion
le mirage 2000d et donc c'est un avion
de chasse biplace pilote navigateur et
en 2002 je le fais un vol à presque de
routine ça fait à peu près une heure de
vol qu'on une heure qu'on est en vol on
vient de faire ravitaillement en vol
donc dans cet avion
on a plus de 6 tonnes de kérosène et mon
pilote me dit mais tes pieds sur les
palonnier les manettes qu'on a au pied
et qu'il n'y a pas un truc bizarre
effectivement ça tremble ça vibre et au
moment où je mets les pieds jeudi et
physiquement il ya un truc d'argent
qu'on entend
ok ça bourdonne en plus à vivre il
commence à y avoir du bruit on commence
à le dire à l'équipier dire on commence
à avoir un truc bizarre et le temps de
lui dire ça y est ça commence à sentir
le brûlé
c'est pas une situation d'avenir en
avion c'est pas parce qu'on souhaite ça
sans brûler on continue d'essayer
d'analyser ce qui se passe et on a des
fumée en cabine dans le cockpit pâle
copie commence à être envie de fumer
alors on passe en cirque d'oxygène de
secours pour passer les fumées sont
toxiques pour pas être pas être
intoxiqué et le plus curieux c'est que
l'avion lui se dit qu'il est bon d'aller
on a des capteurs partout et normalement
dès qu'on a une micro pas non à un
voyant qui s'allument on aime check list
une procédure en paix quelque chose mais
là l'avion milan je vais bien tu vas pas
très bien et est en train de tout sauter
l'ail et des premiers symptômes ils sont
pas terribles mais le meilleur c'est
qu'à ce moment là on youtube
l'afghanistan plus précisément au dessus
de la vallée d'helmand d' l'avait
également ses parties sud de
l'afghanistan près de kandahar où il ya
les cultures de pavot
oui la richesse où il ya les talibans où
il ya des combats
notre mission c'était d'aller porter
soutien aux forces britanniques qui
étaient déjà partis vous imaginez bien
une des solutions qu'on a dans l'avion
quand vraiment et ça se passe pas bien
dans un avion de chasse on a cette
chance d'avoir des sièges éjectables
et si jamais on doit s'injecter où on
sait qu'on sera pas forcément accueilli
avec des colliers de fleurs on va c'est
pas forcément une solution une situation
terrible dans cette zone obscure où on
ne comprend rien à ce qui se passe on a
aucune procédure on n'a rien et puis à
l'enjeu vital qui est l' un des plus
gros danger c'est d'avoir un état de
stupéfaction
c'est le corps qui bouge pas c'est pas
ce qui se passe voilà on se le corps
s'autoprotègent c'est ce que vivent les
personnes qui ont le malheur de se faire
agresser dans la rue on comprend pas ce
qui se passe et ça ça peut arriver à
n'importe qui même à des professionnels
on est là on sait pas ce qui se passe on
a aucune procédure on n'a rien on
comprend rien notre vie est en jeu
mais dans cette obscurité on ne comprend
rien du tout il ya une petite lumière
qui s'allume et je dis à mon pilote ça
te rappelle pas ce qui arrivait à 12 il
ya quelques années doute c'est un
collègue un pilote
il lui est arrivé une histoire similaire
qui nous avait raconté dans l'escadron
le soir après les vols nous avait dit
tiens à ce qui m'est arrivé il ya
quelques jours et nous avise qu'il avait
fait alors c'est quelqu'un qu'on connaît
bien qu'on aime bien
et forcément c'était prochain on fait le
même boulot on s'est dit mais si moi je
m'étais dit mais si ça m'arrivait ce qui
lui arrivait depuis la métropole pour
pour lui qu'est ce que je ferai
qu'est-ce que je serai dans quel état je
devrais être émotionnellement pour
pouvoir gérer de l'inconnu et du
complexe où ma vie est en jeu et je
m'étais projeté je m'étais dit ma faute
d'être que je fasse si les sacs c'est ça
et ça je m'en souviens on est plusieurs
années après je me souviens de cette
histoire qui m'avait raconté à
l'escadron et on en parle avec mon
pilote et on trouve les moyens de gérer
la panne comme on peut et on met le nez
vers kaboul et on va se dérouter sur
l'aéroport international de kaboul
et on a de la chance parce que les
symptômes commencent à disparaître
on arrive à se poser et on se rend
compte le premier diagnostic à peine en
ai posé des mécaniciens ne l'avions en
avait une partie de l'avion qui était en
feu effectivement et là on a beaucoup de
chance c'est que ce feu était contenu
c'est à dire qu' il était compartimenté
il ne s'est pas propagé au reste de
l'avion sinon je serais certainement pas
là pour vous en parler
ce qui nous a sauvés ce jour là ce qui
nous a permis de garder notre calme de
pouvoir analyser cette panne et pouvoir
faire quelque chose c'est très
certainement en grande partie cette
histoire qui nous avait été raconté il
ya quelques années au bar de l'escadron
alors c'est pas un hasard ce qui nous
c'est ce qui c est arrivée quelques
années plus tard anisé marchand et il
s'agira de comprendre quand un pilote de
chasse prend une décision face à une
situation complexe inconnu sous stress
etc d'où ça vient et cette thèse a été
dirigée par rené amalberti les des
connaisseurs apprécions l'expert
français en gestion de systèmes à risque
et elle était très surprise dans la
plupart des récits
sipa la totalité dans la plupart des
récits ça vient l'histoire que les
pilotes ont entendu alors le lieu où on
entend les histoires dans l'escadron le
bar
le bar de l'escadron pour le prix d'un
café ou après les vols d'une bière on
peut avoir la vie qui est souvent parce
qu'on se raconte des histoires parce que
la vie est trop courte je ne pourrais
pas vivre toutes les situations donc ces
sont des gens que j'apprécie qu'ils font
le même métier que moi qui se retrouvent
dans des situations tordues dans
lesquels je peux me retrouver qui me
raconte des histoires et ces histoires
on explique très bien dans sa thèse ça
fait trois quatre cents pages à peu près
1 pour les plus courageux c'est
disponible en ligne elle le dit très
bien c'est parce que voilà on a sept
sont rationnels qui est là et sa mine
empreinte très forte qui peut durer des
années des dizaines d'années on se
souvient inconsciemment d'une histoire
et ça nous sauve la vie aujourd'hui je
travaille dans les blocs opératoires et
on met en place des systèmes de check
list et autres comme on fait dans
l'aviation et pour savoir si dans un
établissement que je ne connais pas si
l'établissement est performant et sûr le
premier endroit que je vais voir c'est
la salle de repos vous n'imaginez pas la
corrélation extraordinaire qu'il y as
entre l'état d'une salle d'europe de
repos dans un établissement hospitalier
au sein des blocs opératoires
s'il ya du monde que on discute il ya du
café il ya des croissants on peut
s'asseoir et des fauteuils confortables
on prend du temps on échange on oublie
qui est infirmier qui est chirurgien
kinesthésique etc
il y a une réelle et très forte
corrélation entre l'état de la salle de
repos et la performance et la sécurité
en salle d'opération
la corrélation est extraordinaire ça
marche dans les deux sens si vous devez
vous faire opérer demandé à visiter des
blocs et particulièrement la salle de
repos peu importe la salle d'opération
tout et c'est bon tout ça la salle de
repos et il ya vraiment une très forte
corrélation ça marche partout savoir que
les avocats qui se retrouve à la caf et
du tribunal et qui échangent et qui
partagent leur expérience ça marche avec
les experts comptables ça va tout les
toutes les sociétés ça marche vous posez
vous la question tient parce que je
rencontre les personnes avec lesquelles
je travaille et on se prend des instants
convivialité c'est informel on parle de
tous des gamins de tout et on parle
aussi du travail et on apprend des
autres et on apprend inconsciemment on
va se projeter un petit peu plus loin là
aujourd'hui on est en 2019 et comment ça
fonctionne pour rester dans le côté
aéronautique
aujourd'hui normalement il ya marqué
vous le dis aujourd'hui une patrouille
aérienne ce qu'on appelle une patrouille
simple le quatre avions de chasse âgé
symboliser quatre rafale ces quatre
pilotes parfois plus parce que si c'est
des avions de chasse biplace comme le
mirage 2000d dans lequel j'ai la chance
de voler ça pète hui personne et ses
huit personnes se retrouvent après la
mission de la journée se retrouvent au
bar on fait un débriefing formule après
on va un petit peu échangé avant de se
quitter on à la tradition de se
rencontrer d'échanger et son que c'est
là que se créent les liens proches on
est un peu plus loin 2039 la partie
droite 2039
ce sera plus le rafale il sera encore là
mais ce sera presque dépassé et son
successeur arrivera le mirage 2000
n'existera plus il sera justement il
viendrait d'être peut-être remplace
remplacé par un c'est plus un avion on
appelle plus un avion on appelle ça un
système de combat aérien du futur c'est
ce que le nom ceux qui ont suivi le
salon du bourget 2019 a été présenté
officiellement sa particularité c'est
qu'il ya un avion certes piloter mais
les équipiers ce sont des drones ce sont
des machines
ces machines sont utilisent des systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle ça marche
très bien
la place de l'homme là dedans pourquoi
on laisse toujours un homme c'est pour
prendre les décisions face aux
situations complexes inconnu combats
aériens etc qui sont qui demande une
adaptabilité temps réel et une
créativité innovation adaptée pour
survivre le problème c'est que le soir
au bar
ouais c'est moins sympa alors on se
doutait entre les robots le machine
learning ces sujets très tendance on se
fait pas de soucis on sait qu'entre ça
va marcher on sait qu'ils vont échanger
des informations
mais moi tout seul là au bar alors
peut-être que je croiserai certainement
les équipages des autres patrouilles
mais ça fait quand même quatre fois
moins une personne que je vais pouvoir
rencontrer d'où va venir les champs d'où
va venir à l'information
comment je vais pouvoir faire tout ça
c'est un ce sont des travaux sur
lesquels on commence seulement à
réfléchir
on commence seulement à se dire mince
quelle sera la place de l'homme quelle
sera la place de normes qui restera dans
ce cas là le bloc chirurgical c'est la
même chose on a aujourd'hui des robots
dans les blocs chirurgicaux
alors on appelle ça musulmans des robots
mais ce sont des machines sont aidés
guidés à distance par le chirurgien ça
peut être admettre ça peut être à 2000
km mais demain on sait aujourd'hui que
ce sera en partie des machines de
l'intelligence artificielle qui opérera
et c'est très bien ça le fera très bien
et une partie des toute une partie des
vols quand vous prenez un vol commercial
c'est la machine qui est elle le fait
très bien le problème n'est pas là c'est
cette petite chose qui doit rester entre
les humains qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
comment est ce qu'on peut continuer à
partager
on doit le préparer maintenant on doit
dès à présent se réserve des temps pour
de l'informel pour partager entre nous
pour nous pour dans mon métier c'est
vital dans d'autres métiers
la chirurgie est vital au cip et pour
d'autres professions
la vitalité elle est là aussi elle est
peut-être pas aussi manifeste que celles
que j'ai pu vivre au dessus de la vallée
d'helmand en 2002 mais elle est là aussi
alors le bar de l'escadron là à cette
heure ci alors il ya peut-être vols de
nuit et être encore ouvert ce n'était
pas le bon moment pour
pour y aller mais je vous propose qu'on
se retrouve pour en parler aux cocktails
tout à l'heure et là on va échanger et
là on va voir quelles sont les idées que
nous avons parce que c'est ce qui nous
sera peut-être la vie demain à tout à
l'heure
merci
[Applaudissements]